we're really learning where the stars
like to mix work and play and there's a
bunch of school work junk here what rule
are you in can you show me it a little
bit my library I called it the lair just
beautiful from the angles that I've seen
and it's thank you yeah we spend a lot
of time right here around not Donnie you
know there's um there's Daisy Danny
welcome to our home and our studio what
room are you in right now we're sort of
we're right by right by the booze which
is helping my wife get through are you
like in the kitchen are you like I'm
sorry kitchen you're gonna get in
kitchen yeah that's a nice-looking
kitchen that's sweet yeah that bad right
the bonus of doing these zooms with all
the stars we get a look inside their
homes drew and Linda's kitchen island is
nine feet long Derek Hough keeps photos
of his family and favorite memories on
his wall Tracy Morgan has Michael
Jackson's glove and that's not all
Tracy geez still have those fish tanks
oh my goodness I am the black Jacque
Cousteau man I'm in a library in my car
shop that I've actually I never come in
because I like it's for quiet reading
Martin right there you can't I don't
know so this is my tea cart from France
everything in here like all my paintings
are like usually from late 18-hundreds
Keith Urban has a studio at his national
home where he holds private concerts for
Nicole and the girls so much to see
really I mean this is kind of it how
many guitars are there Keith
oh yeah is it yes well as a few there
I'm walking out of here with the camera
there's a few there yeah yeah but this
is where we store everything okay what
room are you zooming to us from right
now it's the recording studio it's in
our old farmhouse who's my man cave is
where I had to when I get in trouble and
when I had something creative to do it's
a great space we're loving Chris Cuomo's
giant walls of glass and built-in TV at
his modern home in the Hamptons and we
can also take a tip from a couple Grammy
winners using zooms as a chance to kinda
humble brag by the way I love looking at
your awards it's well actually they're
not to brag Ernie with that that's
actually the real awards right there
what challenges is working out of your
basement present last week you were in
your kitchen yeah I was watching you I
saw you got a nice kitchen Kevin Frazier
[Music]